Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie
So this is going to be my Walking Dead Episode 12 video
The first look inside the Alexandria Safe Zone
We also got to meet a couple people that were right out of the comics
so I'll try to explain them in the most non-spoilery way possible
So just careful for spoilers as I start to explain who these people are
So here we go
Deanna first.  She is a gender-bent version of Douglas Monroe from the comics
and aside from the gender swapping, she's pretty much the same as she is in the comics
She's an Ohio representative, she's a politician, so definitely don't trust her
In the comics Douglas did have a son named Spencer, but on the show Deanna's son's name is Aiden
So Aiden might be a little bit like Spencer in the comics at least in tone
like the characters are both douchebags
but it seems like Aiden's character is gonna be much more aggressive.
Then we have Jessi here, also right out of the comics,
she has a son named Ron
On the show she has two sons,
I don't want to talk about her husband in the comics cause it's a little spoilery, and
they kind of teed it up with Rick walking by their porch
but if your ears pricked up whenever she and Rick were sharing moments
then you're on the right track
In general, it seems like the show is going to be pretty faithful to the Safe Zone of the comics, with a few minor changes
Not quite as many characters
If you have read the comics, and you want to talk about that stuff, just please use spoiler tags
So here we go, top five moments:
Number 5 - Welcome to the Safe Zone
This episode is one of my favorites so far this season
And for very different reasons than I usually get excited about episodes
Usually Walking Dead is all about the gore, all about big zombie kills, really awesome effect sequences
but this episode was all about the group stepping into this alternate dimension
where they just couldn't fathom what was going on
because it looked so weird
it's like they all walk in and they're looking around going "What the HELL is going on here?"
When I first graduated from college, I moved into a neighborhood kind of like that, and I had the exact same reaction.
I was like, "what is going on? These people look like aliens."
That being said, I do think that most of the members of the group have their shit together.
Carol totally isn't drinking the Kool-Aid, Rick knows what's up
I mean he puts that uniform on, but that doesn't mean that he's going to stop being careful
I think the only one from start to finish that just refuses to accept their new reality is Daryl.
Moving on to Number 4 - say good-bye to Rick's beard!
May you rest in peace
This was so funny.  I mean, Andrew Lincoln had been walking around in real life without a beard for a long time
so I think we all felt like, yeah, eventually they're going to trim it
It got so ridiculously long, too
The minute Aaron showed up, clean shaven, you're like, okay, yeah, clearly he is from a place where they own razors.
The beard is not long for this world.
How many years, though did it take off of Rick's life when he cut that beard off?
He's not an old man, but with that beard, he definitely looked like one.
It's like he de-aged by 10 years
the minute he shaved
and how convenient that Alexandra Breckenridge's Jessi character showed up right as he was finishing, no shirt on
Clearly there's going to be some shenanigans going on there eventually
Whenever they cast Alexandra Breckenridge, they made a pretty big deal about it.  She's one of the few
characters, I mean, there's a bunch of new characters at the Safe Zone, but she's one of the few that they made
a big deal about publicizing, so obviously they're going to focus a lot more on her
in terms of all these new people.
That just means that she's going to have a lot more scenes with the group than the other new members of the Safe Zone
I think we're going to be at the Safe Zone for the rest of the season, and so we will have time to meet all those other characters,
but I just feel like they're going to focus more on Jessi.
Moving on to Number 3 - Carl meets all the children
I like the way they have parallels between the group members in the way they experience the Safe Zone
So Carl is like the kid version of Daryl.  Completely cannot figure out how to assimilate.
There is the Enid character, clearly he's going to form a bond with her
I'm kind of interested to see what's going on there
She could wind up being like a Clementine character
from the video game
I don't think she is Clementine, or it could go nowhere, but I'm more inclined to think
that based on the amount of time they spent setting her character up
teasing that something was going to happen between her and Carl
that they will pursue that
Definitely something going on with Rich-onne, with this new Jessi character and Rick, and now Carl has this new Enid character
Just a lot of new friendships that are going to be born
Think about it this way, too, a lot of times, if the  Walking Dead ends up really liking an actor, if their performance ends up being way better than they originally thought it would be
sometimes they'll turn them into cast regulars in future seasons
Robert Kirkman has said a number of times, though, that this season will be much more faithful to the comics
So, just regardless, look forward to a lots of comic book things
Moving on to Number 2 - The Survivors clash with life at the Safe Zone
So everyone acts out just a little bit in their own way.  Carl and Rick have that weird moment where they get super cranked up to kill walkers together
I guess it's like their version of catch
Their version of playing catch in the backyard.
And they you have Glenn, Tara, and Noah, clashing with Aiden's group
Clearly Aiden is off his rocker.  They're all just having a hard time assimilating.
I mean Daryl is just the best visible example of that.
It's like taking a wild dog and putting it in a house, like, it will just keep freaking out til it adjusts.
Or til you let it back outside.
And finally, my number one moment - Rick says that if it doesn't work out, don't worry, we'll just take the place.
The way he said that too, such a great delivery
So casual
Like, don't worry, We'll just take it, no big deal.
He and Carol are so funny, like it's like they're wearing these weird clothes, now, like Carol's dressed like a housewife
He's dressed like he used to as a sheriff, but underneath they're not taking any bullshit.
I would say of all the camera performances, Carol's was my favorite, though.  Everyone else seemed so earnest.
Like Rick was honest, he's like "Close your gates, don't trust anyone"
Carol, though, was like "OH, I'm just a den mother, I love working with other people."
"Do you have any jobs in the community? Do you have a Junior League?
Any organizations that I can help?"
Just the way her face looked while she was saying that seemed so earnest and so funny.
I just wanted to laugh so hard.
Clearly she is just playing this politician.
And that's another thing, too.  What is going on with Deanna?
If she's a politician, that means that she lies for a living.
And if she's good enough to win re-election, that means she's really good at manipulating people.
I think just right now, since she's just met these people, what she's doing is she senses that they're really tough
so she's keeping them close.
Like she's trying to make friends with them right away.
If you were to meet someone who you sensed was more powerful than you,
you'd have a much easier time if you befriended them rather than turn them into an immediate enemy.
Doesn't that just feel like a politician thing to do?  Like if you saw an opponent that you thought might be able to beat you in a future election
You would try to turn them into an ally.
rather than keep them from becoming an enemy or potential threat in the future
But let me know though, of all the things that they teased in the episode,
like potential future conflicts with certain people, especially with Jessi's weirdo husband smoking creepily on the porch
what are you most excited about?
One of the fun things I'm really looking forward to is just seeing Glenn beat the shit out of Aiden
again
there's no way he's going to let that go.  Aiden is totally going to challenge him again at some point.
I already mentioned most of the comic book easter eggs I saw,
like all the people that they pulled straight off the page, but if you saw any that I didn't mention,
just list them in the comments below.
I think one of the things that we need to look out for is who took Rick's gun, what's going to happen with the other members of the community that we haven't met yet
and what is Aiden going to do to get revenge on Glenn?
Based on what they put in the teaser for the next episode, I think we're going to learn a lot more about Deanna
next week.  So, I think we'll find a little bit more about what's going on inside her head.  What her grand plan is for the survivors.
And remember the producers and Robert Kirkman have said that we're going to meet a villain this season that's just as bad as the governor
and the people at Terminus.
Don't you just wonder if it's someone that we met in this episode?  Because I don't think it's going to be Negan.
I think he's still a little ways off.
So just a quick reminder new round of the giveaway starts now.  All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment below.
But I'll be posting next week's video after the episode airs.  Generally I'm actually really excited with the direction the show is going
right now.  I mean it's weird because the tone of the show is changing so much, but I think that's a good thing.
So while you guys wait for my next Walking Dead video or for the Q&A tomorrow, you can click here
for last week's episode, and you can click here for my latest Game of Thrones episode
Learn all about Dark Sansa.
Thank you so much for watching, I'll see you guys tomorrow
High fives!
<<music>>